اكبر خطورة على الطائرات
والاقمار الصناعية التابعة
دورها الاستراتيجي وامكاناتها في
مجال خوض الحرب الفضائية سيشكل
وبهذا تقول روسيا لطائرات
الولايات المتحدة وانظمة دفاعها
الامريكان هناك بكل ما اوتوا من
قوة. روسيا طورت اسلحة يمكن ان
ونهارا وفي الظروف الجوية وعلى
خلفية التشويش المعادي المكثف
بما فيها الصواريخ المجنحة
الصغيرة الحجم والمروحيات
بمثابة طائرة واعدة معقدة مناورة
في الفضاء واعتراضية. لكن القدرة
الذي قد يبلغ مائة كيلو متر اي
حدود الفضاء. مع قدرة فائقة على
المشاريع المغلقة من صناعة
الدفاع الروسية الحديثة. وستكون
المدار بمساعدة الصواريخ حتى
كانت تستخدم لذلك. واحدة من اهم
الاهداف على مسافة تصل الى
ثلاثمائة كيلومتر ليتم استبدالها
بعد بعض الوقت بصواريخ بمدى يصل
الى اربعمائة كيلومتر. وكل هذا
ينتهي بعد. ويضاف لترسانة
اسلحتها. صواريخ قادرة على ضرب
التخفي المتقدمة ومسلحة بجميع
انواع الصواريخ الروسية الحديثة
الجوي كوش ملك فميد فوتي وان
بسهولة فوق الاراضي الامريكية
الفضاء الالكتروني. هي اثقل
الطائرات المخصصة لخوض العمليات
القيام بدوريات طويلة الامد
والتعامل مع كافة انواع الاهداف.
على المناورة لا تعتبر امرا بالغ
الاهمية بالنسبة لمقاتلة
الارضية وطائرات الانذار
الراداري المبكر لاعتراض
العالم. اطلاق اقمار صناعية الى
المدار. من لن تعمل في الفضاء
دون ان تتعرض للاصابة من قبل اية
دروع جوية او صاروخية. يصرخ
الحربية في الجو واسرع قادرة على
تبادل المعلومات مع الرادارات
الطائرات الشبحية المعادية على
مسافة مئات الكيلومترات. لكن
وتحديد الاحداثيات والملاحة
بواسطة الاقمار الاصطناعية.
للنايتو. برأيكم هل تعتبر ميج
فوتي وان هي الطائرة الاقوى
ثلاثة وثمانين ولكن هذا يكفي
لاعتراض قاذفات العدو وصواريخ.
ستكون الطائرة قادرة على اسقاط
صواريخ تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت.
المعلومات التي تمكن الطيار من
الاطلاع على الوضع الجوي للمعركة
الاعتراض بصواريخ فرط صوتية.
والاهم بالنسبة لها هو الارتفاع
فقد تم تزويدها بمنظومة مراقبة
حديثة ذات شاشة كبيرة لعرض
والطائرات فوق الصوتية المحلقة
على ارتفاعات عالية. وذلك ليلا
تعطل اقمارنا الصناعية او تدمرها
من الارض او في الفضاء او في
الا من بعض المعلومات التي خرجت
سهوا عن موسكو والصين لتستلقفها
في حين ستعمل صواريخها في الفضاء
ستكون قادرة على اسقاط اقمار
طائرة. قدرات خارقة لمقاتلات
الجيل السادس. وفوق كل ذلك
العدو او على العكس من ذلك.
اطلاق الصناعية صغيرة الحجم الى
المتطورة مقاتلة اعتراضية بسرعة
عالية جدا تبلغ اربعة الى اربعة
مع القادمين من كواكب اخرى.
طائرة القيصر الروسي بوتين
وحسب بل ستزود المقاتلة باحدث
الاجهزة الالكترونية هوائي مرحلي
يسمح لروسيا على مقاتلة من
الطراز السادس ليس لها نظائر في
وكذلك مواجهة الطائرات الاسرع من
الصوت بفعالية يمكن ان تصل سرعة
عاما تقريبا. تصميم لاداء مهام
قتالية معقدة في درجات حرارة
وبذلك تصبح المقاتلة تجسيدا حيا
لكلمة السرعة مزودة بتقنيات
بما في ذلك الصاروخي الاسرع من
الصوت مهلا مهلا فتسليحها لن
يجعلها اسرع طائرة في العالم. في
حين تصل سرعة الى اثنين فاصل
الفين وثلاثة ويتم تنفيذ جميع
الاعمال في جو من السرية التامة
اخرى. الروسية ستتسلح بصواريخ
حتى ان وسائط الدفاع الجوي
المتوفرة في العالم لا تستطيع
ايقاف هذه الصواريخ. اسرع طائرة
مواصفات فضائية تمكنها من
التعامل مع القادمين من كواكب
التي ستحل محل طائرة الاسطورية
التي تم تشغيلها لاول مرة قبل
منخفضة في القطب الشمالي وفي
ظروف قاسية بالقرب من الفضاء
ميكفو تيوان الى اربعة اي نحو
خمسة الاف متر في الساعة ما
فيكتور بوندريف متباهيا ليقول
باسرع مقاتلة في العالم وستقدر
وماذا بعد هذا ماذا تركت للدول
الاخرى لتصنع? قادرة على التعامل
الفين وسبعة عشر. خرج القائد
السابق للقوات الجوية الروسية
مقاتلة اعتراضية سرعتها ثلاثة
تحلق على ارتفاعات عالية ومع ذلك
في العالم. يعمل الدب الروسي على
تطوير هذه المقاتلة منذ عام
المخابرات الامريكية بكل شغف.
وهناك شيء واحد فقط يقال بثقة
تامة. هذه الطائرة من الجيل
السادس هي واحدة من الطائرات
اعتمدنا عليهما في انشاء هذا
الفيديو بالاضافة الى مصادر
الخامس سيعفو عليها الزمن بعد
فورا اتجهت موسكو لشركة ميكوين
بامريكا. لكن الامر لن يكون كذلك
بالنسبة للجيل السادس فالجيل
تأخرت روسيا كثيرا في انتاج
مقاتلات الجيل الخامس مقارنة
حضور بعض المصادر. اليكم المصدر
الاول. صحيفة المختصة بالشؤون
اخرى. هل هذه حقيقة ام خيال? ما
هذا الذي اقوله? اذا لابد من
العسكرية العالمية. لكم ايضا
مصدر مجلة العالمية اللتين
فاصل ثلاثة اي اربعة امثال سرعة
الصوت من صاروخ فرط صوتي وليست
المنتظرة استأثرت باهتمام
الاعلام الاجنبي. الخفية
اهدافها. عن طائرة الفضاء
الروسية نتحدث وللقصة بقية.
على اعتراض اهداف فرط صوتية وهي
طائرة شبحية قادرة على اخفاء
المصنعة للمقاتلة الروس يريدون
تطويرها وعن اي تطوير نتحدثي ون
تستغرب ان اخبرتكم ان هذا
المسلسل سيكون جزءا من حاضرنا.
ابرقي ارعدي ابطالا وعدوك ام بلا
وعد. جاءوك بصوت الحق الهادر
قامت طائرة باول رحلة لها في عام
الف وتسعمائة وواحد وثمانين.
نفسها عن الرادارات المضادة.
ويمكن تحويلها الى طائرة مسيرة
لتبدأ الشركة الروسية العمل على
مشروع صنع مقاتلة جديدة عام
المتحدة بل وسيدمرها في الارض او
في الفضاء سلاح سيجعل الناتو في
التخفي مرعبة اقوى انظمة الرادار
تصطاد الاهداف الفضائية ولا تخطئ
حتى من الصواريخ. الطائرة التي
حيرت العالم برمته قدرتها على
وتائهة. انها طائرة الفضاء
الروسية. طائرة فرط صوتية اسرع
كازي من رعد. انا اعتذر فصوتي
ليس جيدا للغناء. لكن هيه لا
خطر يا سادة. روسيا تصنع مقاتلة
تجعل الاقمار الصناعية عمياء
والاسرع في العالم المصادر صحيفة
سورو الصينية مجلة مجلة صحيفة
الاهداف الفضائية اصبحت من
الماضي. بعد ان اصبح الخيال
حقيقة بوجود هذه الطاير. السلاح
الذي الاقمار الصناعية للولايات